Speaker 1: At the heart of the entire Alex Jones
defamation trial and now the award phase and all
of the viral videos that we've been looking at at
the heart of all of this are the original claims
made by Alex Jones about the Sandy Hook shooting
a decade ago. And the central element of those
claims is that at one point Alex Jones said it
was all fake. It was a false flag orchestrated
by whoever the government then to create a
pretext for the confiscation of firearms. And
a critical moment during this defamation
trial that we've been watching this week
is when Alex Jones concedes that the Sandy
Hook attack was 100% real. Now, does Alex Jones
actually mean this or is he saying it because now
he has been pushed into a corner and he believes
this is how you minimize the damages that he will
ultimately be responsible for. Well, let's take a
listen to the moment where this happened.
Speaker 3: To the end of 2014.
We've had a video received in evidence
of you stating your belief at that time.
Speaker 4: That no one died at Sandy Hook,
that the whole.
Speaker 3: Thing was faked.
Do you understand as you sit
here today, how crazy what
I have said before, that there have been so many
lies and so many things in the past, and I was
under a lot of pressure. And I truly when I said
those statements, when I say something, I mean it,
that I really couldn't believe that it was totally
staged at that point. And I was basing that off of
really Steve Shattuck, who is a
has been a very prestigious person.
Speaker 1: Do you even in getting to
saying that he now recognizes it was real,
he's still defending why he thought it was fake.
Speaker 3: And now that it was
absolutely irresponsible of you. It
was, especially since I at the parish
and it's 100% real. As a summary of
your show. As I said here, you're saying
it's 100% real and the media still ran with lies
that I was saying it wasn't real on air yesterday.
It's incredible. They won't let me take it back.
They just want to keep me in the position of being
the Sandy Hook man. My son got in trouble.
Speaker 4: Yesterday's conjunction
speculation is what the media wants, Mr. Jones.
Speaker 1: It's just all right. So now he goes
off topic and it's interrupted. Now, do we believe
Alex Jones actually believes this now, or is this
just a set up for some future Infowars exclusive
about how the Deep State and the Bilderberg is and
the Dracula family forced Alex Jones to apologize?
Or is it going to be? Well, the attack was real,
but everything leading up to it and everything
afterwards, it's all part of some larger
conspiracy. I don't know. I don't know. I'm
not sure whether he is genuinely sorry for what
he did and he believes that it was wrong, met
empirically wrong, or that he's just upset that
he's now being held accountable. I don't know the
answer to that, but I'm curious to hear from you.